[Musik]
bradley smith der amtszeit auf den
stufen des kapitols und in schweren
zeiten eine rede die kraft geben soll
für die zukunft
[Musik]
josef robert beiden junior ist der 46
präsident der usa
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend hinein an
einem tag für die geschichtsbücher hat
ja es hier für den sport nachher in der
sendung kännchen guten 14 jahre donald
trump an der macht sind vorbei
die usa haben einen neuen präsidenten
die amtseinführung in washington heute
anders als jemals zuvor in der
geschichte
ohne die üblichen hunderttausende
zuschauer vor ort dafür mit sorge vor
dem corona virus und vor möglichen
attentaten joe biden und seine vize
präsidentin kamera harris stehen jetzt
vor einer großen herausforderung
wir beginnen heute abend mit britta
jäger in washington
die flügeltür öffnet sich für den 46
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
wenig später hebt er die rechte hand zum
schwur
seit gut einer stunde ist joe biden
offiziell im amt ich schwöre feierlich
dass ich das amt des präsidenten der
vereinigten staaten treu ausführen und
nach besten kräften die verfassung der
vereinigten staaten bewahren schützen
und verteidigen werde
in seiner feierlichen rede an die nation
im anschluss setzte er den ton für die
nächsten vier jahre
joe biden spricht vor allem von einheit
von versöhnung
ich bin mit meiner ganzen seele dabei
mit meiner ganzen seele bin ich dabei
heute meine ganze seele steckt da drin
um uns zu vereinen unsere nation zu
vereinen
und ich bitte alle amerikaner mir dabei
zu folgen schreibt us geschichte als
erste schwarze frau im amt
[Musik]
die nacht vor der amtseinführung hatten
der präsident und die first lady in spe
in sichtweite des weißen hauses
verbracht am morgen dann zunächst ein
kirchenbesuch während sich am kapitol
die zuschauerplätze füllten zunächst
unter anderem mit senatoren und
abgeordneten dann mit den ex präsidenten
barack obama george hw bush und bill
clinton
auch vize präsident mike pence ist
gekommen
der hatte beiden vorgänger nicht
persönlich verabschiedet donald trump
blieb der amtseinführung fern vor dem
kapitol ein fahnenmeer 200.000 flaggen
stellvertretend für die zuschauer die
nicht zur amtseinführung kommen durften
wegen der korona pandemie und aus
sicherheitsgründen die hauptstadt wie
leergefegt wie eine festung gesichert
25.000 nationalgardisten schützen beiden
vereidigung die sorge vor
ausschreitungen oder anschlägen ist groß
am späten vormittag dann macht sich die
beiden mit seiner frau jill auf den weg
zum kapitol so wohl ungewöhnlichsten
amtseinführung der us geschichte
gemeinsam mit carla harris betreten sie
das gebäude
[Musik]
lady gaga singt die nationalhymne
sie hatte joe biden auch im wahlkampf
unterstützt
[Musik]
und joe biden hat eine botschaft für die
die vor nicht einmal zwei wochen das
capitol hinter ihm gestürmt hatten
wir stehen hier nur tage nachdem ein
wütender mob dachte er könnte gewalt
anwenden um den willen der menschen zu
unterdrücken um unsere demokratie zu
stoppen uns vor diesem heiligen grund zu
vorjahren
es ist nicht passiert ist wirklich
passieren nicht heute nicht morgen
niemand
am nachmittag wird joe biden ins weiße
haus einziehen und von dort aus die
politischen zügel in der hand haben für
die kommenden vier jahre über die
politik reden wir gleich erstmal helm at
wissen in washington frage an sie was
ist denn das für eine atmosphäre in
einem abgeriegelten washington heute an
so einem tag
ja es ist schon ein stück weit so real
weil normalerweise hier tatsächlich
200.000 menschen jubeln würden wenn sie
die rede von joe biden gehört haben das
ist so nicht man sieht die 2000 die da
waren
da gibt es lächeln das kann man
zumindest erahnen hinter den masken das
ist ein land den krisen aber ich glaube
trotzdem dass der präsident mit seinen
worten die sehr ehrlich und sehr
bodenständig waren zumindest versucht
hat auf augenhöhe mit den menschen auch
mit den anhängern von donald trump zu
kommen und er hat ihnen ganz klar gesagt
hört mich einfach an lass mich ausreden
und lasst es auf euch wirken und wenn
ihr dann immer noch anderer meinung seid
dann könnt ihr eben anderer meinung sein
das ist so in einer demokratie
also ich glaube es war eine rede die
ankommen könnte aber ob sie das tut das
werden wir erst noch sehen
ein zerrissenes land eine furchtbare
pandemie viele herausforderungen liegen
vor beiden wie wird er denn heute
jenseits seiner rede politisch diese
amtszeit beginnen wird heute noch
mindestens 15 dekrete unterzeichen
exekutiv für fehler
die betreffen verschiedene punkte allen
voran natürlich die pandemie will corona
hilfen für die amerikaner die leiden
unter dieser großen pandemie er wird
auch die zusammenarbeit mit der
weltgesundheitsorganisation wieder
aufnehmen
durch die usa im bereich umwelt will er
auf jeden fall wieder dem pariser klima
abkommen beitreten und er hat auch heute
vor zu unterzeichnen ein dekret mit dem
der stopp eines baus einer pipeline
tatsächlich wieder verhängt wird die von
donald trump genehmigt wurde auch im
einwanderungs bereich wird der
veränderungen vornehmen er will denen
die illegal hergekommen sind und ihre
kinder hier in usa bekommen haben den
will eine möglichkeit geben bürger
amerikas zu werden also eine ganze
palette und das beginnt heute nur das
wird über die nächsten zwei wochen
weitergehen mit einer ganzen zahl von
dekreten herzlichen dank nach washington
und wir gucken jetzt noch mal genau auf
diesen neuen us-präsidenten auf ein
leben in der politik
siebenmal wurde joe biden in den senat
gewählt
acht jahre lang war er vizepräsident von
barack obama
doch sein leben war auch geprägt von
tragischen ereignissen benjamin daniel
mit einem porträt er gilt als mann der
niemals aufgibt nach 50 jahren in der
politik nach schweren schicksalsschlägen
wird joe biden der älteste us präsident
der geschichte
ich verspreche euch ein präsident zu
sein der nicht spalten sondern
zusammenführen will biden ist ein
fleißiger aber durchschnittlicher
jurastudent der noch vor seinem
abschluss seine große liebe nie
geheiratet
mit erst 29 jahren wird er zum us
senator gewählt
dann der erste schicksalsschlag lilia
und die gemeinsame tochter sterben bei
einem autounfall jahrzehnte später
stirbt sein sohn wo an einem hirntumor
beiden biografie ist eine öffentliche
leidensgeschichte die er in seinem
wahlkampf für sich genutzt hat seine
botschaft ich bin der gegenpol zu trump
höre euch fühlen mit euch beiden hat
viele erfolge vorzuweisen wie die
gesundheitsreform obamacare die er mit
verhandelt hat es gibt aber auch
schatten über seiner karriere
so stimmte er für den irakkrieg der zum
desaster wurde oder sorgte als justiz
ausschussvorsitzender nicht für eine
faire anhörung
als einem kandidaten für den obersten
gerichtshof sexuelle belästigung
vorgeworfen wurde
sein jetziges versprechen die nation
wieder zu einem könnte zu seinem größten
erfolg werden oder zu seiner größten
niederlage der eine kommt der andere
geht in den letzten tagen war donald
trump kaum noch aufgetreten sein name
fiel bei der offiziellen amtseinführung
heute kein einziges mal
wie also würde der bisherige präsident
seinen abgang inszenieren er dessen
markenzeichen des war tabus zu brechen
mit regeln und traditionen der mit
offensichtlichen lügen politik machte
und sich von seinen fans immer wieder
feiern ließ einer der selbst mit
diktatoren flirtete heute morgen kurz
nach 8 uhr ortszeit endete seine ära im
zentrum der macht in das trans es ist
das letzte mal dass präsident trump das
weiße haus verlässt einmal noch daumen
hoch
in der nacht hatte er noch eine welle
umstrittener begnadigungen ausgesprochen
für loyale weggefährten die ihn in der
zukunft nützen könnten mit dabei auch
sein ehemaliger chef berater steve
bennett angeklagt wegen betrugs kampf
bleibt sich treu bis zum schluss früh
morgens verlässt er washington stunden
vor der vereidigung seines nachfolgers
die amtsübergabe als zeichen einer
friedlichen machtübergabe lässt er aus
ein bruch mit der tradition
stattdessen eine militärisch anmutende
feier auf dem flughafen
vor einer ungewohnt kleinen gästeschar
trump ist isoliert
es folgt eigenlob joe biden name erwähnt
er nicht
ich wünsche der neuen regierung viel
glück und viel erfolg
sie werden großen erfolg haben denn sie
haben die grundlage etwas richtig
spektakuläres zu machen wir haben das
land in die position gebracht wie es nie
zuvor war noch immer gesteht er seine
niederlage nicht klar ein
zum abschied worte die zumindest eine
hälfte des landes als drohung verstehen
wird auf wiedersehen wir lieben euch wir
werden zurückkommen in irgendeiner form
wir waren keine normale regierung sagt
ramm bevor mit der air force one
richtung florida fliegt er hinterlässt
ein zerrissenes land geteilt durch an
den tiefen graben voller hass hass den
er befördert heute ist ein guter tag für
die demokratie sagt bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier zur
amtseinführung des neuen us-präsidenten
allen anfeindungen zum trotz hätten sich
amerikas institutionen als stark
erwiesen
eu-ratspräsident schelmisch l stellt den
usa einen neuen gründungs pakt zur
zusammenarbeit in aussicht und
eu-kommissionschef in ursula von der
leyen sagt nach vier langen jahren werde
europa wieder einen freund im weißen
haus haben
was bleibt von trump was wird beiden
jetzt tun weitere analysen gleich in
einem zdf spezial direkt nach uns und in
unserer app können sie sich den neuen
arbeitsplatz von joe biden schon mal
anschauen
das openoffice in 3d unser zweites
großes thema heute der kampf gegen
korona viele stunden lang hatten
kanzlerin und länderchefs gestern
verhandelt und gestritten
das ergebnis die virus regeln werden bis
mitte februar verlängert und zum teil
verschärft schulen und kitas sollen
grundsätzlich geschlossen bleiben hier
ist aber schon klar die bundesländer
werden das wieder sehr unterschiedlich
regeln für ganz deutschland gilt fb2
oder op masken pflicht in bus und bahn
und beim einkaufen
und das dritte große thema home office
überall wo es möglich ist muss der
arbeitgeber das arbeiten daheim zu
lassen mehr von andreas ruppert computer
und schreibtische verweist stille da wo
sonst büro und industriekaufleute
arbeiten beim anlagenbauer thema setzen
sie in der verwaltung voll auf home
office und das schon seit wochen
es ist ein weg um die kontakte natürlich
zu beschränken im grunde dass die größte
gefahr für die mitarbeiter sehe ich
heute auf dem pendel weg also jetzt eine
auswertung planungen oder berichte geht
dann kann man das alles von zu hause
machen kontakte minimieren um das virus
zu bekämpfen
genau das ist es worauf man sich gestern
beim corona gipfel geeinigt hatte der
bundesarbeitsminister liegt deshalb
heute eine arbeitsschutzverordnung vor
darin werden arbeitgeber unter anderem
verpflichtet ihre beschäftigten mit
hochwertigen atemschutzmasken
auszustatten
außerdem wird das home-office
verpflichtend geregelt vorerst befristet
bis mitte märz also wir verlangen nichts
was nicht möglich ist und wenn der
arbeitgeber darlegen kann dass es
betriebliche gründe gibt die dagegen
sprechen dann muss das nicht gemacht
werden aber da wo es möglich ist sollte
es gemacht werden und muss es auch
gemacht werden einen grundsätzlichen
rechtsanspruch soll es nicht geben
allerdings können behörden im
zweifelsfall betriebe kontrollieren die
home office verweigern unverständnis bei
vielen arbeitgebern
das ist natürlich ein hoher
organisatorischer aufwand keine frage
aber das passt ins bild denn die letzten
jahre hat uns die politik immer mehr
bürokratie beschert das ist eine
belastung für die unternehmen ist auch
eine belastung für den standort ab
nächsten mittwoch gilt die verordnung
zum verpflichtenden home office
bundesweit eine regelung die werner
brust in seinem unternehmen schon jetzt
erfolgreich praktiziert sondern auch
theo koll mit dazu und haben eine enorm
lange diskussion gestern und jetzt dann
doch verhältnismäßig wenig beschlüsse
wie passt denn das zusammen
ein polyp politisch passt es sogar
perfekt zusammen denn die stundenlangen
diskussionen zwischen kanzleramt und
einigen ministerpräsidentinnen waren ja
ein ausdruck für die unterschiedlichen
meinung zu den vorgeschlagenen
beim thema schulen und kitas zum
beispiel hat es ja unendlich lange
gedauert bis sich die kanzlerin
zumindest in einem punkt durchsetzen
konnte und auf einer restriktiven
umsetzung der grundsätzlichen
schulschließung bestand und dann dauert
es nur einen moment bis der erste
ministerpräsident dann doch wieder
abweichungen ankündigte bei sinkenden
infektionszahlen hat die kanzlerin ganz
offensichtlich mühe gehabt mit ihrer
sorge vor den virus mutationen zu
überzeugen
und wahrscheinlich wird sie auch deshalb
morgen vormittag noch einmal länger vor
der hauptstadtpresse versuchen ihre
position zu erklären
vielen dank und dann schauen wir uns
jetzt die aktuellen zahlen an ziel der
maßnahmen soll ja sein die sieben tage
inzidenz auf unter 50 zu drücken aktuell
liegt der bundesweite schnitt bei 123,5
innerhalb eines tages zählte das
robert-koch-institut 15 1974
neuinfektionen
das sind rund dreieinhalbtausend weniger
als vor einer woche
sehr hoch bleibt die zahl der todesfälle
1148 menschen starben in verbindung mit
dem virus
und jetzt in der sendung noch wichtige
entscheidungen der bundesregierung heute
das kabinett legt einen entwurf für
kinderrechte in der verfassung vor
künftig soll es dort heißen dass das
kindeswohl angemessen zu berücksichtigen
ist für eine grundgesetzänderung braucht
die koalition allerdings eine
zweidrittelmehrheit und damit stimmen
der opposition
ebenfalls auf dem weg ein neues
verpackungs gesetz für weniger müll
die gastronomie soll künftig
mehrwegverpackungen für ihre produkte
zum mitnehmen anbieten müssen
außerdem ist ein pfand auf alle getränke
behälter aus plastik geplant also auch
für säfte und zum jahresende soll
schluss sein mit dem töten von
männlichen küken hab dann können laut
kabinett verfahren eingesetzt werden die
das geschlecht schon immer erkennen so
dass männliche küken gar nicht erst
schlüpfen in der spanischen hauptstadt
madrid ist ein gebäude explodiert
mindestens drei menschen kamen ums leben
über mehrere etagen riss die detonation
die fassade ab augenzeugen berichten von
trümmerteilen die weit durch die luft
flogen
elf verletzte mussten behandelt werden
in dem gebäude waren büros und wohnungen
für priester das innenministerium
spricht von einer gasexplosion
schreckliche bilder aus mattiert sein
schnitt hier in der sendung und wir
machen den sport und das bist ja stimmt
ja
wir beginnen mit handball das
viertelfinale war das minimalziel der
deutschen handballer bei der
weltmeisterschaft in ägypten
doch dieses vorhaben könnte nun ins
wanken geraten denn gestern abend verlor
das team von trainer alfred gislason
sehr knapp gegen das team aus ungarn
strahlender sonnenschein und was
aussieht wie ein abschied ist jetzt
einen neuanfang reisetag in ägypten für
deutschlands handballer ein neues hotel
alles fein wären da nicht die
erinnerungen an die niederlage gestern
und die eigene enttäuschung jetzt gilt
es nach vorn zu schauen auf spanien
das ist ein ganz abgezockte mannschaft
die in der regel im turnierverlauf auch
immer besser wird vielleicht ist es gut
dass wir sie dann jetzt schon kriegen
der wm zeitplan ist eng die
möglichkeiten zu üben für die slawistin
sind begrenzt heute haben sie trainiert
akribische vorbereitung auf den
europameister
das muss ich ja nicht einfach aber wir
wollen durchaus zu müssen und aber dafür
dürfen wir nicht so viele fehler machen
von der schönsten seite zeigen wollen
sie sich morgen und nicht baden gehen
gegen spanien heute abend beschließt die
fußball-bundesliga ihre hinrunde und das
überraschungsteam von genau dieser ist
union berlin
die berliner spielen zitat des eigenen
trainers eine außergewöhnlich gute
saison und so wird das spitzenspiel bei
rb leipzig sehr erwartet vor einem jahr
boykottierten union fans noch das
auswärtsspiel nun wären sie womöglich
gerne angereist als anerkannter
favoritenschreck der aktuelle beweis
heimsieg gegen die starken leverkusener
lob allenthalben dann ja finde ich auch
spieler verpflichtet in den letzten
jahren wo jetzt nicht jeder bundesligist
dran war die haben sie außergewöhnlich
gut gut entwickelt letzte saison war
union in beiden spielen die die
leipziger noch klar unterlegen
doch die kommen nur schwer aus der
winterpause zuletzt zwei spielen ohne
erfolgserlebnis für die nagelsmann
schützlinge du musst sehr vieles richtig
machen
wenn du einen punkt aus leipzig
mitnehmen könntest eins ist klar vor
union berlin müsste inzwischen jeder
gegner gehörigen respekt haben
[Applaus]
jetzt erwarte ich die lottozahlen von
dir
das ist sehr schön die kann ich nämlich
liefern katja hier sind sie die
gewinnzahlen 5 6 11 31 35 42 superzahl 0
das war jetzt im schnelldurchgang
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie aber
auch auf lotto zdf de oder im zdf text
da ist die seite 557 beim wetter kommen
sturm und regen osten terry hat gleich
mehr
im heute journal empfehlen die kollegin
marietta slomka 21.45 jetzt gleich nach
uns wie erwähnt das zdf spezial zum
neuen us-präsidenten von uns allen bis
morgen danke fürs zuschauen und ihnen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein sturmtief
erreicht deutschland und bringt im
westen viele wolken und wie der name es
schon sagt aus südlichen richtungen auch
sturmböen
ansonsten im osten und im südosten ist
es noch trocken dort temperaturen bis
minus 6 grad frostig kalt im westen
deutlich will dabei plus 9 grad morgen
tagesverlauf ziehen sturm und regen
rasch nach osten ja unter vorher gibt es
noch etwas sonnenschein in den östlichen
landesteilen von südwesten drängen neue
wolken mit regen ins land zu sturmböen
müssen sie mit rechnen im tagesverlauf
dann temperaturen bis 4 grad im südosten
sonst werte um die zehn grad marke
häufig teils darüber 12 grad im
südwesten und in den östlichen
landesteilen und in den nächsten tagen
am freitag weiter regen und allmählichen
den mittelgebirgen schnee bei fünf bis
elf grad und ab samstag wird es
allmählich wieder kühler damit ein
schöner abend